para hablar con experta en numerosos
daniela blandón pero pues con una
noticia no muy alentador a los 100 días
invasión ucrania dejan graves estragos
económicos y comenzamos con el lado ruso
claro que si raúl pues desde que inició
la guerra occidente ha impuesto a un
estimado de 5 mil sanciones contra rusia
para tratar de ahogar su economía lo más
reciente es el posible veto que se va a
imponer al la importación de petróleo
por parte de europa ahora no es
solamente el país más sancionado del
mundo sino que tiene alrededor de 300
mil millones de dólares en oro y
reservas internacionales congelados y
esto le ha impedido realizar cómodamente
sus pagos de deuda internacional la
escuela económica de kiev se calcula que
unas mil empresas han huido o recortado
sus operaciones en este país caso mentón
al secas o starbucks o coca-cola entre
muchísimas otras el principal índice de
bursátil de la bolsa de moscú también ha
perdido una cuarta parte de su valor y
el rublo se ha fortalecido pero esto es
gracias a los controles de capital
impuestos por el kremlin pero quizás una
de las consecuencias más notables hay
que ver precisamente con que europa está
dejando de depender del petróleo y del
gas de uno de los más grandes
exportadores del mundo eso el lado ruso
cómo están las cosas de la ucraniana
bueno ucrania cree que la guerra ha
borrado de un plumazo el 35 por ciento
de su producto interno bruto que es
bastante dependiente de su actividad
agrícola el gobierno calcula que las
pérdidas directas ya ascienden a unos 60
mil seiscientos mil millones de dólares
sin contar los 22 millones de toneladas
de cereales quietos en los puertos que
han sido capturados por moscú así es es
danny y este impacto nosotros ha quedado
en estos dos países sino que ha
traspasado todas las fronteras raúl como
lo hemos venido notando pues esto generó
todo un impacto inflacionario que ni
siquiera se había vivido en los peores
momentos de la pandemia del 19 no
solamente en rusia en ucrania también en
todo el mundo ya que estos dos países
son grandes despensas de alimentos sólo
en trigo son responsables de una tercera
parte de lo que consume el mundo y el
maíz tienen una cuarta parte además
rusia es un gran exportador de
antes también por otro lado las
cotizaciones de petróleo hoy son entre
un 20 y un 25% más altas y eso impacta
directamente en los precios de los
combustibles de los alimentos entre
muchos otros productos y vamos ahora a
hablar de uno de los protagonistas de
esta sección teníamos ya días sin hablar
de él y por supuesto vamos a hablar de
él on mouse pero de tesla una de sus
empresas porque tendría que eliminar
puestos de trabajo bueno la historia es
la siguiente raúl hay un correo enviado
por el dueño de la empresa y lo moscú a
sus empleados y conocido por la agencia
reuters en el que dice que el
multimillonario tienen muy mal
presentimiento sobre la economía y que
necesita eliminar un 10 por ciento de
los más de 100 mil empleos del
fabricante de autos de lujo este mensaje
fue enviado el jueves y está titulado
como pausar todas las contrataciones en
todo el mundo y se produjo apenas dos
días después de que el considerado
hombre más rico del mundo causará
polémica por decirle a su personal que
regresará a su lugar de trabajo o que
quedaban
este anuncio se suma también a un
creciente coro de advertencias de los
líderes empresariales sobre los
eventuales riesgos de recesión a pesar
de que justamente hoy salieron datos de
mercado laboral en eeuu mejores de lo
esperado dice que la tasa de desempleo
se mantuvo estable en un 36 por ciento
seguimos hablando de este personaje con
una de las que serían sus empresas vamos
a ver si realmente va a pasar qué ha
pasado con twitter band y después de
twitter informó este viernes que el
tiempo de espera regulatorio para la
adquisición de la empresa por parte del
multimillonario ya expiró eso quiere
decir que se despeja el camino para que
continúen con el acuerdo valorado en más
de 44.000 millones de dólares ahora que
falta la aprobación de los accionistas y
de otros también avales de regulatoria
vamos a ver entonces quién que va a
parar esta novela de twitter y pasamos a
otra información porque la mayoría de
los países de nuestra región creció en
el primer trimestre se han tirado ya hay
varios países que han dado cuenta de su
comportamiento económico en el primer
trimestre como por ejemplo colombia que
lidera con un 85 por ciento frente al
mismo período del año pasado
también chile
y méxico con valores que van desde el 18
por ciento en el peor de los casos hasta
el 72 por ciento y brasil acaba de
informar que su crecimiento interanual
hasta marzo fue del 17 por ciento
impulsado por el sector de servicios sin
embargo la inflación que ya pasa del 12%
y las altas tasas de interés siguen
siendo un problema
estamos ajustando nuestros márgenes de
ganancia para poder mantener nuestros
precios intactos todavía no transmitimos
los aumentos de inflación en nuestros
productos pero nuestros márgenes se
redujeron en aproximadamente 15% el
gobierno siempre está hablando de seis
ocho o diez por ciento de inflación pero
eso no es lo que notamos ya sea para
combustible electricidad alimentos hemos
visto aumento de precios muy por encima
de eso danny gracias como siempre por
toda la información de economía ya a
descansar feliz fin de semana nos vemos
no mentira la semana que viene viene
jorge usted en la próxima semana bueno
dan y nos vemos entonces cuando venga
aquí la esperamos pasamos a saludar a
luis méndez con todos los deportes